Speaker 1: All right.
One more Trump thing before we move on to
other things, Donald Trump published a statement
yesterday in which he demands that Mike Pence
actually be investigated for not stealing
the election.
Now there's a really great article in Vanity
Fair from Bess Levin about this, where she
describes she.
She describes Trump's statement as febrile
and grammatically offensive, which is maybe
the best way to describe.
Any Trump statement that I've ever heard,
and we're going to look at that statement
in a moment, I encourage you to actually read
the article front by Best 11 in Vanity Fair.
But the point here is that not only is Trump
saying he wanted Pence to overturn the election,
and we're going to we've learned more about
this in the last 48 hours.
He actually thinks maybe there should even
be an investigation into Pence.
So here is the statement put out by Donald
Trump yesterday.
And again, it's it reads like one of these
tweets and there's random capitalization and
all sorts of different things.
Quote so pathetic to watch the UN Select Committee
of Political Hacks, Liars and Traitors work
so feverishly to alter the Electoral College
Act so that a vice president cannot ensure
the honest results of the election.
When just one year ago they said the vice
president has absolutely no right to ensure
the true outcome or results of an election.
In other words, they lied, and the vice president
did have this right or more pointedly, could
have set the votes back to various legislators
for reassessment after so much fraud and irregularities
were found now.
That's not true.
We looked already at the 12th Amendment and
the Electoral Vote Act.
I believe it's called of eighteen eighty seven.
I think I'm now not remembering it the year.
I think it's 1887.
We looked at this earlier in the week.
It's already clear to ninety nine point nine
percent of people that Mike Pence can't overturn
the election or do the things Trump wanted
him to do.
The reason that now the language is is considering
being updated is specifically because of bad
actors like Trump, who are either deliberately
or out of ignorance, misunderstanding what
the powers of the president of the vice president
are in counting electoral votes.
OK, back to the statement as it gets even
crazier if it were sent back to the legislators,
or if Nancy Pelosi, who is in charge of Capitol
security, had taken my recommendation and
substantially increased security.
That's a lie.
By the way, there would have been no January
6th as we know it.
Now it's fascinating to see Trump say on the
one hand, the rioters are being treated unfairly
and he'll give pardons to some of them.
And the sentences are unfair, while at the
same time saying Nancy Pelosi upping security
could have prevented it if they didn't do
anything wrong and they're being treated unfairly
and being punished when they shouldn't be
punished.
Why is it we needed?
Why would security need to stop people from
doing something that wasn't a problem?
It's completely incoherent, as you can tell.
And then Trump going on to say, therefore,
and this is like the key whacked out line.
Therefore, the UN Select Committee should
be investigating why Nancy Pelosi did such
a poor job of overseeing security and why
Mike Pence did not send back the votes for
recertification or approval, in that it has
now been shown that he clearly had the right
to do so.
Trump is out of his mind.
This is I mean, he this is officially losing
it.
It's also sort of a partial walk back of his
previous statement.
He now the previous statement was Pence could
have overturned it.
He seems to be walking it back by saying what
Pence could and should have done is send it
back to the states for recertification.
Pence also can't do that, but it is a walk
back of that original statement, which was
even more unhinged.
But the theme here is it's always someone
else's responsibility and someone else's fault.
Pence is to blame.
Is to blame.
Brad Raffensperger is to blame Joe Biden,
whoever people who allowed voting by mail.
It's never I'm to blame because I didn't get
enough votes.
I didn't convince enough people to vote for
me.
It's that's never the explanation, and I saw
a funny comment on Reddit about this sort
of like faux mirage alpha male status of Donald
Trump.
And it read what kind of person listens to
him and says, Yes, this is the big, strong
man as opposed to this is what it sounds like
when my child loses a video game and this
this is completely over the top and beyond
the pale.
And this is the world of a narcissist.
It's we've spoken to psychologists and others
before.
Everything is someone else's fault.
Trump blames others for losing the election.
Trump blames others for not fulfilling what
he believed or asked them to do in terms of
overturning the election.
And at the end of the day, this will never
change.
When you are this deluded and narcissistic.
This is how everything is seen through this
lens.
We'll have some of these statements and clips
that we looked at in this segment on our Instagram,
which you can find
at David Pakman show.